ministre
on va démarrer cette réunion je vous
prie d'abord d'excuser une partie de nos
collègues comme j'avais eu l'occasion de
vous le dire nous sommes à la veille
d'un long weekend il y a des problèmes
de transport beaucoup de nos collègues
qui ont il y a déjà aussi des collègues
qui sont en mission profitant du fait
que cette semaine
offre un pont assez important
mais ceci ne doit pas porter atteinte à
la qualité des échanges que nous devons
avoir et il était assez compliqué de
reporter sauf à choisir une date très
lointaine donc on est bien évidemment
toujours très heureux même ministre de
vous accueillir et de faire avec vous le
point de grands dossiers de votre
ministère alors tout d'abord bien sûr
l'actualité oblige le président
ukrainien président zenki était à Paris
ce dimanche dans le cadre de sa tournée
européenne
préparant sa contre-offensive pour
s'assurer du soutien de des pays
européens
donc à l'issue de cette tournée qu'il
amené à Rome Berlin Paris Londres le
président
ukrainien a obtenu de nouvelles
livraisons d'armes mais il n'est pas
parvenu à ce stade à convaincre la
France ou l'Allemagne de lui fournir des
avions de combat vous nous direz madame
la ministre quels efforts accompli la
France pour soutenir l'Ukraine et quelle
ligne rouge nous semble pour l'instant
un francisable néanmoins est-ce qu'il
est véritablement compréhensible pour
nos concitoyens nous nous pouvons le
comprendre en tant que commission de la
défense met-il vraiment compréhensible
pour nos concitoyens que nous proposions
de former des pilotes sur Mirage 2000
mais que nous refusions de leur fournir
les avions en question on peut
évidemment poser la question et elle
nous est posée cette question évidemment
par ailleurs les Britanniques ont fourni
à l'Ukraine des missiles de longue
portée Storm Shadow qui est l'équivalent
de notre scalp français comment
expliquer la différence de position sur
ce sujet entre nos deux pays
enfin la facilité européenne pour la
paix tient-elle les objectifs que vous
aviez fixés et vous paraît-elle
suffisante
par ailleurs des voies s'élèvent
notamment dans les pays baltes pour
accélérer l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'OTAN à quelques semaines du sommet des
chefs de l'état des chefs d'État et des
gouvernements de l'alliance qui va se
tenir à Vilnius les 12 et 13 juillet
prochain alors que nous avons sans doute
fini d'examiner le projet de LPM la
question des relations entre l'Ukraine
et l'Alliance et entre l'Ukraine et
l'Union européenne va se poser
indiscutablement quelles sont les
perspectives quel est votre sentiment
sur sur ce sujet donc d'adhésion à
l'OTAN et à l'Union européenne de nos
amis ukrainiens
l'avenir de l'Alliance dépend aussi des
décisions de la Turquie tentant ce qui
concerne l'adhésion de la Suède que le
rôle qui est le temps de jouer dans le
conflit ukrainien comment voyez-vous
évoluer cette situation alors que le
second tour des élections
présidentielles turques aura lieu le 28
mai prochain
nous nous posons également des questions
sur l'évolution de l'Inde qui sera
invité l'invité d'honneur du président
de la République le 14 juillet prochain
la raison la récente des fêtes du BJP
dans le sud du pays comme l'éviction du
leader d'opposition Raoul Gandhi font
débat et une récente tribune dans un
quotidien du soir un site à la prudence
vis-à-vis de ses alliés stratégiques
vous ne direz madame la ministre quel
est votre perception de cette relation
avec l'Inde
je reviens maintenant au continent
africain dans toute sa multiplicité vous
le savez madame ministre à l'initiative
de
l'initiative d'un groupe de notre
assemblée nous entendrons le 6 juin
prochain une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat en application de
l'article l50-1 de la Constitution
relative à la politique étrangère de la
France en Afrique la question du
positionnement de notre pays qui subit
de plein fouet la désinformation des
pays rivaux la défiance des pouvoirs
locaux et bien sûr et je pense bien sûr
au Mali cette question est évidemment
posée alors quelle est notre réaction
face à ce qui paraît être une perte
d'influence de la France quelles sont
nos priorités nos objectifs et les
moyens déployés dans ce domaine les
ambitions les ambitions affichées
trouvent-elles bien une traduction
concrète des moyens adéquats et à bonne
hauteur tant en personnel quand
ressources financières une question qui
nous est là aussi souvent posée
je souhaite
m'arrêter là de telle sorte de pouvoir
laisser la place d'abord à votre
intervention et aussi à l'échange avec
notre collègue nous aurons bien sûr
j'imagine quelques questions sur
l'évolution du corps diplomatique à
laquelle vous le savez notre commission
est très attentive notamment dans la
mise en œuvre de la réforme je rappelle
que c'est audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site Sénat
comme vous en avez maintenant bien
l'habitude madame la ministre je vous
cède la parole pour une présentation
générale puis après nous entamons un
échange entre nous
sont ouverts voilà ils le seront si
j'appuie sur le bouton merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs merci de votre
invitation à m'exprimer à nouveau devant
votre commission et j'ai bien suivi par
ailleurs les travaux qui ont été les
vôtres en auditionnant tel hôtel
ambassadeur ambassadrice aux
personnalités de mon ministère merci du
suivi attentif que vous faites de notre
petite étrangère je vais m'efforcer
d'aborder les différents points que vous
avez soulevé monsieur le Président à
travers un propos plus général et je
reviendrai bien sûr plus spécifiquement
sur des questions complémentaires que
vous voudriez vouloir me poser et je
voudrais ouvrir mon propos sur deux
succès récents de bonnes nouvelles pour
notre diplomatie et sur le cap fixé par
le président de la République lors de sa
visite tout à fait exceptionnelle au
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères le 16 mars dernier en
conclusion des états généraux de la
diplomatie pour tracer ce cap d'une
diplomatie mieux armée réarmée dit-on
une diplomatie agile et de combat mais
d'abord les les deux bonnes nouvelles en
premier lieu la libération de nos deux
compatriotes Benjamin briierre et
Bernard félon ce dernier étant
franco-irlandais mais donc français deux
compatriotes qui ont été retenus sans
aucune raison en Iran le premier depuis
trois ans trois ans et le second pendant
8 mois
l'un comme l'autre était en situation
physique extrêmement difficile malade
ayant besoin de recevoir des soins et
ils ont pu enfin rentrer chez eux sur la
base je dirais d'un
d'une considération humanitaire pour
laquelle nous avons plaidé et qui a pu
convaincre les autorités iraniennes de
procéder à leur libération je souligne
qu'il y a eu une excellente coordination
entre les différentes administrations de
l'État qui ont pu un titre ou un autre
avoir à fournir cet effort de façon à
permettre ce résultat
il nous reste quatre compatriotes
emprisonnés de qui ont été en Iran au
début du mois de mai donc il y a
maintenant un an et deux qui ont été
détenus plus récemment en septembre en
octobre au moment du début des grandes
vagues de mouvements en dirant sachez
que bien évidemment notre objectif est
de les sortir en bonne santé le plus
rapidement possible nous en parlons
régulièrement je dirais même sans
relâche auprès des autorités iraniennes
je les fais au moment de ma dernière
conversation avec mon homologue iranien
le jour même vendredi dernier de la
libération de Benjamin Brière et Benhard
donc nous exigeons et je le lui redis
leur libération immédiate sans condition
et le plein respect des conventions
deviennent le deuxième succès la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est la
protection de nos ressortissants qui
étaient au Soudan
ce pays est reparti dans des difficultés
malheureusement bien sûr mais nous avons
pu mener
avec succès une opération réussie et qui
correspond là aussi à ce que l'équipe
France peut faire quand tout le monde
travaille bien ensemble de façon fluide
bien coordonnée depuis le début des
combats entre l'armée du général Boran
les f.as et les forces paramilitaires du
général et méthyl et RSF qui ont éclaté
mi-avril nous avons eu avec le président
de la République et tout le gouvernement
de priorités
assurer la sécurité de nos
ressortissants d'une part et convaincre
les deux généraux de respecter une trêve
humanitaire pour cela dans un premier
temps espérant ensuite bien sûr qu'elle
soit prolongée
durable et des bouches sur un processus
politique vous savez que ce titre nous
n'y sommes pas encore mais dans toute
cette opération d'évacuation nous avons
dû maintenir des contacts étroits
réguliers à différents niveaux avec les
deux généraux et avec leur représentants
correspondant sur le terrain vraiment
jusqu'au niveau des différentes
checkpoints de même que nous avons agi
en bonne liaison avec les pays voisins
du Soudan et des pays un tout petit peu
plus lointains dans la région mais qui
ont une influence avérée sur l'une et
l'autre
et donc pendant une semaine
notre ambassade le centre de crise et de
soutien du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères ont été en contact
avec chacun de nos ressortissants de
façon à pouvoir préparer les opérations
de regroupement et ceci alors même que
les combats faisaient rage dans cartoon
mais que vivre électricité au manquée et
que même les liaisons téléphoniques
étaient très largement interrompu
l'opération d'évacuation elle-même était
extrêmement complexe risqué puisqu'il
s'agissait de faire passer nos
compatriotes dans une zone qui était
pour l'essentiel détenus par une partie
les RSF et de les faire progresser sain
et sauf jusqu'à l'aéroport qui est à une
vingtaine de kilomètres au nord de
Khartoum et qui est tenu par les fesses
donc les forces du général pour un
qui se posait des accords au moins
partiels entre les uns et les autres le
samedi 22 avril l'armée française a pu
ouvrir la voie le présent de la
République et également à mon niveau
moi-même nous avons pu obtenir des deux
généraux des assurances que nous étions
mesures de passer sans être pris à
partie nos forces sont donc posées sur
l'aéroport de cartoon et sont parvenus
ensuite dans la nuit à sécuriser le
trajet entre l'aéroport jusqu'au
centre-ville où nous avions pu établir 3
points de regroupement au total puisque
vous avez pu suivre tout ça nous avons
évacué plus de 1000 personnes dont
236 français et ayant droit
comme vous l'avez vu non seulement notre
tradition
et cette heureux et de ne pas nous
occuper seulement de l'évacuation du
personnel diplomatique contrairement à
certains pays même à beaucoup de pays
qui lorsqu'ils doivent évacuer
s'occupent de leur personnel
diplomatique et de nul autre mais notre
tradition sonore de pratiquer la
solidarité et d'aider les autres dans
toute la mesure où nous le pouvons et
c'est donc ainsi que sur ces 1000
personnes évacuées un quart seulement
était de nationalité française et
évidemment je dois préciser qu'il s'agit
là de la totalité des Français qui avait
indiqué vouloir partir nous avons pu
l'assurer et les trois quarts étaient
des étrangers ressortissants de plus de
70 pays
cette opération était saluée par tous
nos partenaires et compris de façon
publique et on les en remercie
opération réussie qui a reposé je le dis
à nouveau parce que je crois que c'est
important de tirer quelques réflexions
de cette expérience d'une très bonne et
très précise coordination entre les uns
et les autres pendant plus d'une dizaine
de jours et puis je rends vraiment
hommage à nos équipes sur le terrain
notamment notre ambasserie ses équipes
et les personnels du centre de crise que
nous avions pu déployer à Djibouti puis
l'aéroport
évidemment pour réussir il faut au moins
temporairement avoir bâti des liens de
confiance avec les protagonistes deux
jours comme de nuit ça a été un travail
constant
ça montre combien
nous sommes
[Musique]
en situation d'avoir acquis d'Orsay
organisé et efficace et combien il faut
donc souhaiter que ça se poursuive mais
c'est l'objet du second point que je
voulais évoquer qui est
le moment et le moment sans précédent je
peux même dire historique monsieur le
Président je vais juste vous me le
permettez je vais juste vous interromper
une seconde parce que je vais rajouter
une troisième bonne nouvelle qui ne
relève pas directement de votre
ministère mais pour lequel vous avez
vous-même beaucoup fait nous venons
d'apprendre que le Parlement roumain
autorisé la vente de deux sous-marins
scorpen enfin de l'achat de deux
sous-marins scorpen à la France vous
savez que ça fait des mois pour ne pas
dire des années que cette affaire traîne
et donc c'est autorisation via des
données par le Parlement Parlement
roumain je sais aussi la part que vous
avez prise donc je voulais rajouter ça
aux bonnes nouvelles de la journée merci
beaucoup Président c'est un dossier
effectivement ancien est suivi par
toutes les autorités de l'État et nos
bonnes relations avec la Roumanie y
compris dans le cadre de la guerre en
Ukraine nous y viendrons
excellentes ambassadrices qui va quitter
son poste mais pour un poste encore ce
n'est pas plus prestigieux il n'y en a
pas d'autres mais qui correspond à ces
talents comme à ses vœux et à ceux du
président de la République
j'en venais donc un resituer ces deux
succès dans un cadre plus large qui est
celui de la transformation et du
réarmement d'autres diplomatie le
présent de la République est venu le 16
mars au Quai d'Orsay parler à des
diplomates se faire présenter leur
travail sur le fond et c'est sans
précédent je dis bien sans précédent et
d'autre part annoncer les décisions
qu'il avait prises en coordination avec
bien sûr la première ministre sur le
les orientations les besoins qui étaient
ses yeux ceux du Quai d'Orsay tente en
moyen qu'en demande de sa part que nous
fassions davantage un certain nombre de
choses la consultation à laquelle nous
avons procédé dans le cadre des états
généraux de la diplomatie était
elle-même inédite c'est vraiment la
première fois que nous avions ouvert la
possibilité à tous les agents auxquels
soient quel que soit leur grade et quel
que soit leur statut de s'exprimer ils
ont été nombreux à participer ce qui
était bon signe et ils ont apporté
beaucoup beaucoup d'idées
très bon rapport merci d'avoir été
associé les uns les autres et en
particulier vous même monsieur le
Président de ce travail puisque le
président salué un bilan son
complaisance du rapport
bon à fond une réflexion solide et des
propositions crédibles donc voilà un
triptyque qui est de qualité mais enfin
historique aussi si l'on veut parler de
façon pratique pour cette maison par
l'annonce de moyens en hausse et vous
savez que c'était une première depuis 30
ans puisque à l'exception du budget du
PLF 2023 que vous avez bien voulu
approuver et bien la dernière fois qu'il
y avait eu une augmentation d'emplois au
Quai d'Orsay c'était 1993 et donc
pendant 30 ans nous avons connu une
attrition continue des moyens tant
humain que budgétaire avec un plateau
néanmoins les deux dernières années je
salue cette occasion le l'excellent
travail qui avait fait Jean-Yves Le
Drian pour stabiliser au moins les
moyens budgétaires du quai enfin nous
avons maintenant donc beaucoup mieux et
avec une visibilité qui était
indispensable puisque nous avons un
schéma plus réanuel avec 700
équivalentes en plein comme on dit dans
l'administration supplémentaire pour les
quatre ans à venir après les 100 de 2023
et une hausse de nos crédits d'un peu
plus de 20% pour atteindre les 7,9
milliards d'euros en 2027 je ne veux pas
comparer le budget du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères avec
celui des armées c'est le président mais
vous voyez qu'on est de terrain assez
différents LPM ou pas LPM enfin nous
avons désormais un quai d'Orsay renforcé
avec une diplomatie qui a enfin les
moyens humains et matériels de ces
ambitions et donc ça doit nous permettre
de faire plus mais pas seulement de
faire plus surtout de faire mieux et
donc de nous transformer le quai rejoint
ainsi cette un type indispensable je
pense mouvement de renforcement de
réarmement du régalien à laquelle
d'autres ministères avaient pu procéder
mais pas celui-ci et donc nous y voilà
le président a demandé quatre grandes
lignes de transformation rendre notre
diplomatie plus réactive avoir une
diplomatie qui déploie résolument une
politique d'influence
diplomatique qui prend le tournant des
enjeux globaux et enfin une diplomatie
plus proche des Françaises et des
Français et je m'efforcerai en revenant
sur chacune de ces quatre grandes
orientations de traiter quelques-unes
des questions que vous avez abordées
graines et autres la première
transformation c'est donc d'être en
mesure de mieux nous adapter monde qui
est en mouvement en perpétuel mouvement
et même peut-être on voit d'accélération
comme on le souligne souvent mais qui
est également de plus en plus
conflictuel fragmentés difficiles et qui
nécessite plus que jamais une diplomatie
à la fois agile et cohérente le cas de
la région du golf me paraît à ce titre
tout à fait caractéristique on peut
réfléchir à partir de cet exemple
face à la perspective d'un Iran qui est
proche du seuil nucléaire donc proche
des seuil de fabrication d'une bombe
nucléaire pour être très claire les pays
arabes vous l'avez vu en infléchi de
toute façon très rapide presque
soudaines leur politique dans ce qui est
peut-être le changement le plus
significatif dans la région depuis 10
ans ou plus depuis les printemps arabe
l'Iran et l'Arabie on normalisé leur
relation en grande partie sous l'égide
de la Chine et l'Arabie Saoudite
d'autrefois
faire de lance du soutien à l'opposition
armée syrienne
à entrepris un rapprochement
spectaculaire avec Damas ont surmontant
l'absence de consensus entre les
partenaires arabes ou on le bouche qui
l'ont puisque vous l'avez vu la série
est désormais invitée à rejoindre le
sommet de la Ligue arabe qui soutiendra
le 19 donc en un mot les choses ont très
vite et avec parfois des mouvements
soudains et en rupture avec la politique
passée
et donc Benja alassa est en voie de
réintégrer son environnement régional
alors il faut être clair les pays
concernés ont leur raison et on leur
intérêt mais nous avons nous aussi des
intérêts dans ce dossier et nous avons
des intérêts propres à défendre que j'ai
rappelé récemment mes partenaires
européens aussi à quelques-uns de mes
partenaires arabes soutient à nos alliés
Kurdes et la lutte contre daesh n'est
pas terminée
lutte contre le terrorisme d'une façon
plus générale
lutte contre le trafic de drogue qui
appartient de la Syrie étant passe de
contaminer de nombreux pays de la région
lutte contre l'impunité il faut
continuer d'en parler ce régime a commis
des crimes et des crimes affreux et puis
soutien au retour volontaire et dans de
bonnes conditions des réfugiés ils sont
des millions des millions et on a
tendance accès humanitaire alors face à
cela nous devons encore mieux analyser
pour
mieux anticiper comprendre mieux
déployer notre action réagir plus vite
c'est un exemple il y en aurait beaucoup
d'autres
je parlerai également dans ce cadre du
dossier
ukrainien
chacun évidemment en mesure l'absolu
centralité pour notre raison
géopolitique
et c'est un dossier comme l'autre qui
reflète plus que jamais la nécessité de
d'être cohérent et d'être en mouvement
en même temps et ça a été la ligne du
conduite depuis plus d'un an de la
France et de l'Europe nous avons réagi
de façon rapide et forte et nous avons
réagi avec une ligne claire et il faut
que ce soit encore le cas à l'avenir car
il est possible de cette guerre soit
appelée à durée si nous ne parvenons pas
à ramener la Russie à la raison je
reprends l'expression du président de la
République et donc en clair à d'autres
comportements c'est c'est son agression
nous devons être absolument mobilisés
parce que la guerre déclenchée par la
Russie en Ukraine est une grave remise
en cause de nos équilibres géopolitiques
et des fondements de notre architecture
de sécurité collective et quel que soit
l'issue du conflit le fait que ceci est
existé continuera de se faire sentir
encore une fois quel que soit l'issue du
conflit
mais évidemment les conséquences seront
encore plus dramatiques c'est la
réussite devait l'emporter c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous œuvrons pour
aider l'Ukraine à exercer son droit à la
légitime défense et feront tout pour
qu'elle puisse
exercer ce droit sur le plan militaire
d'abord puisque vous parliez monsieur le
Président de la récente visite dimanche
du président ski à Paris
et avec le chef de l'État le président
ukrainien a beaucoup parlé de sujets
militaires et notamment d'armement donc
sur le plan militaire d'abord avec un
effort significatif de notre part pour
doter au plus vite l'Ukraine des
matériels essentiels pour mener sa
contre-offensive nous sommes pas seuls
d'autres pays le font mais la plupart
des équipements qui avaient été demandés
et décider l'occasion de la visite
précédente à Paris du président zzinski
ont été livrés ou le seront d'ici la fin
de ce mois je pense notamment aux
munitions de 155 mm qui sont nécessaires
pour les Césars en particulier des
véhicules blindés véhicules de l'avant
blindé de nombreux véhicules avaient été
fournis d'autres ont été livrées des
chars légers à MX 10c même situation ou
encore des mistrales et de tous ceux qui
concerne la défense Ant et le président
a également annoncé vous y avez fait
référence monsieur le Président la
possibilité de former des pilotes
ukrainiens
pourquoi former des pilotes Ukrainiens
sans parler des avions le président la
redit nous le disons depuis le début de
cette année au moins il n'y a pas de
tabou aucune décision n'est prise aucune
n'est
inimaginable mais aujourd'hui ce ne sont
pas les besoins de l'Ukraine par
ailleurs
il faut distinguer
la formation
des pilotes et notamment la formation de
base qui peut être pratiquée sur
différents types d'appareils et la
formation finale est spécialisée qui
pourra être faites dans un second temps
peut-être par des partenaires européens
ou autre puisque le président de la
République a évoqué ses coopérations
j'espère très c'est clair en vous
donnant cette direction et en soulignant
cette distinction entre deux temps et
deux types de formation
le soutien se fait aussi au niveau
humanitaire et civile tant à l'échelle
européenne
qu'à l'échelle nationale je pense
notamment aux nouveaux convois de
matériel de sécurité civile que vient de
remettre notre ambassadeur aux autorités
ukrainiennes cette semaine ou deuxième
laboratoire ADN unité mobile que nous
sommes
l'un des rares pays d'ailleurs à pouvoir
fabriquer et donner compte tenu de cette
technologie qui a été livrée le 9 mai
jour symbolique pour aider l'Ukraine à
lutter contre l'habilité en pouvant
identifier les victimes et donc
documenter les crimes de guerre commis
par ailleurs nous travaillons activement
avec les bailleurs et nos entreprises à
la reconstruction du pays d'ores et déjà
mais aussi dans l'optique de sa
convergence progressive avec les
standards énormes européens le président
de la République a nommé il voulait vu
un envoyé spécial pierrelbronn pour
coordonner l'action de la France à ce
titre pierre est LeBron qui est donc une
lettre de mission signée du chef de
l'État mais qui est placé auprès du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères et sous mon autorité
mais cette action de se limite pas à la
relation bilatérale notre
diplomatie c'est je crois déployer et
même c'est cette remarquer depuis le
début de la crise par sa capacité
d'initiative et d'entraînement je vous
rappeler le rôle que la France a joué en
juin 2022 pour que l'Union européenne
décide d'octroyer le statut de candidat
à l'Ukraine comme à la Moldavie vous
souvenez du déplacement de des
présentateurs républiques à Kiev le 16
juin en compagnie du chancelier Schulz
du président romain et du Premier
ministre italien d'abord quelques jours
à peine avant l'avis de la Commission
européenne précédent la réunion du
Conseil européen qui a permis cette
décision même capacité je crois
d'initiative et d'entraînement lors des
trois votes pléniers à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies ou encore se
traduisant par de très fortes majorités
au soutien de l'Ukraine pour condamner
l'agression russe et pour demander la
Russie encore tout récemment le retrait
immédiat complet et inconditionnel je
cite de ces troupes
même capacité je crois que on l'a vu
mieux après la visite peut être que
pendant la visite avec la visite d'État
du président de la République merci
beaucoup en Chine qui a joué je peux
vous l'assurer un grand rôle dans le
fait que le président de ping quelques
semaines après et alors que ils en
avaient parlé avec le président de la
République a appelé le président
zzzleinski ce qui n'avait pas fait
depuis le début du conflit et vous avez
vu que l'envoyer spécial chinois va
faire le tour de quelques capitales est
entre Moscou et Kiev je crois en ce
moment et viendra notamment à Paris en
tout début de semaine prochaine
et enfin soutien sans faille et
complet que nous avons rappelé ce
week-end lors des échanges du président
de la République avec son homologue
ukrainien ce sera le cas si l'on se
projette un peu dans le calendrier à
l'occasion du sommet de l'OTAN qui se
tient à Vilnius en juillet prochain 11
et 12 juillet ou je crois que fort de
notre poids venant de notre contribution
de premier plan au renforcement du flanc
oriental de l'Alliance nous pourrons
jouer un rôle et je n'en doute pas pour
conforter les liens entre l'Ukraine et
l'Alliance atlantique sans franchir trop
vite des étapes qui seraient impossibles
et inopportun de franchir en ce moment
je rappelle normocla France se présente
en Roumanie y compris sur le plan
militaire et comme nation cadre qu'elle
est également présente avec des forces
et du matériel en Estonie et qu'elle a
assuré son tour de rotation dans les
cieux baltes à partir de la Lituanie où
elle reviendra pour reprendre le retour
de rotation qui concerne l'ensemble de
la zone Baltique elle reviendra donc au
mois de décembre
puisque vous évoquiez le rapprochement
avec l'OTAN et avec l'Union européenne
je précise tout simplement que le
processus
menant vers l'Union européenne pour ce
qui concerne l'Ukraine suit la méthode
de base la méthode qui s'applique à tout
candidat et qui est une méthode claire
elle est basée sur le mérite comme on
dit et donc par rapport aux demandes qui
avaient été faites
lors de l'octroi du statut de candidat à
l'Ukraine et bien cahier des charges à
remplir avec cette grande réforme la
Commission fera un rapport dit oral au
mois de juin sur l'état d'avancement
sujet par sujet préparant son rapport
définitif en fin d'année
rapport définitif qui lui-même orientera
très largement la décision que prendront
les chefs d'État ou de gouvernement au
Conseil européen de décembre
je souligne à nouveau sur le fait que ce
soutien
de la France de l'Europe de ses amis
alliés s'inscrira dans la durée parce
que ce qui est en jeu c'est bien sûr le
sort de l'Ukraine en tant que pays
souverain indépendant et dans
l'intégrité de ces frontières c'est bien
sûr le sort des ukrainiennes et des
Ukrainiens mais au-delà même de
l'Ukraine il s'agit vraiment de l'avenir
d'un système international fondé sur le
droit et du refus de voir prévaloir la
logique du plus fort ou de voir
récompenser des agressions
cette préoccupation
globale nous l'apportons également sur
le conflit qui oppose l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan ou plusieurs affrontements
ont lieu depuis le 13 septembre les
difficultés se sont transformées en
incidence sporadique je me suis rendu
dans les deux pays il y a quelques
semaines avec un message tout à fait
clair montrant le fait que la France est
engagée comme le président de la
République avait été pour aider ceux de
pays au dialogue lors du premier sommet
de la communauté politique européenne le
6 octobre engagé pour soutenir une paix
durable pour inciter les deux parties à
rechercher l'apaisement des tensions et
à rechercher une reprise des
négociations encore plus active au
bénéfice évidemment de leur population
mais évidemment
la paix ne peut être venir et être
et durable que si les principes
fondamentaux du droit international sont
respectés dans cette région comme
ailleurs c'est d'abord le respect de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie et
donc le retrait de l'Azerbaïdjan des
positions prises illégalement depuis le
mois de septembre mais c'est aussi des
garanties fortes pour que les
populations arméniennes du haut-karaba
puisse continuer d'y vivre et d'y vivre
dans le respect de leurs droits de leur
culture et de leur histoire et ça
implique enfin je l'ai dit aussi tant au
président Alif car
ces ministres ça implique de mettre fin
au blocage illégal du corridor de la
jink et la voix d'accès qui mène vers le
garaba comme la demander explicitement
la Cour internationale de justice qui a
dit le droit et donc nous avons rappelé
que le droit doit s'appliquer
la France continuera d'agir aussi dans
un cadre européen comme elle le fait
depuis le début c'est grâce à sa
mobilisation que les Européens ont pu
décider
avec des difficultés convaincre
l'aservation de ne pas s'y opposer
qu'une mission d'observation de l'Union
européenne soit déployée du côté
arménien de la frontière donc la mission
est bien du côté herminal de la
frontière ça a été fait ça a été
possible et la mission était prolongée
même renforcée je m'y suis rendu dans le
cadre de cette vie que j'ai faite dans
la région en allant djermouk qui est le
lieu d'où l'on voit par ailleurs très
bien
certaines
incursions de la part de l'Azerbaïdjan
cette mission a permis de faire baisser
les tensions pas totalement mais elle a
eu un rôle extrêmement positif chacun le
dit
limite évidemment les risques d'exalan
par sa présence physique et par les
patrouilles qu'elle mènent jour après
jour et elle permet aussi de documenter
objectivement avec des informations
extrêmement précises ce qui se passe au
bénéfice des États membres de l'Union
européenne puisque c'est ça mission
c'est une mission d'observation nous
restons par ailleurs pleinement
mobilisés en soutien la médiation
conduite par l'Union européenne
et on soutient à ce complémentaire et
bien coordonné qui sont déployés par les
États-Unis
[Musique]
nous sommes très actifs aussi dans
l'Indopacifique et je crois pouvoir dire
que les contacts avec cette région n'ont
jamais été aussi intense parce que la
guerre en Ukraine ne détourne en rien au
contraire des enjeux dans cette région
qui est essentielle pour nos intérêts et
qui fait l'objet d'une stratégie
française depuis 2018 donc nous sommes
actifs et avançant dans la mise en
oeuvre de cette stratégie
en fait les deux
sujets sont liés puisque nous cherchons
à obtenir des pays de l'Indo Pacifique
nombre d'entre eux entretiennent de
bonnes relations avec la Russie qu'ils
s'investissent et qui s'investissent
davantage dans la recherche d'une
solution
qui soit évidemment une solution
respectueuse des principes du droit
international a commencé par la Chine et
l'Inde et nous cherchons aussi d'une
façon plus générale développer
pardonnez-moi notre présence est une
relation avec ces pays afin que il ne
soit pas
seul face à un grand partenaire et qu'il
dispose d'une plus grande liberté de
choix à eux ensuite de choisir mais nous
voulons être là être présent pour qu'ils
aient cette possibilité de choisir cette
liberté de choisir nous venons
d'ailleurs de tenir à Stockholm samedi
Stockholm sous présidence suédoise du
Conseil de l'Union européenne une
réunion des ministres des Affaires
étrangères des 27 et de la plupart des
pays de l'Indo-Pacifique dans le cadre
de cette stratégie
nous menons aussi dans la zone des
missions de souveraineté pour y défendre
le droit international et notamment mais
pas seulement et défendre la liberté de
navigation je l'ai fait encore récemment
en me rendant sur l'une des frégates
françaises qui est basée dans la zone
indopacifique le préalable qui est basé
en
Polynésie française qui a exercé sa
mission de souveraineté de respect tant
des intérêts économiques des pays de la
zone que trois international d'une façon
générale et notamment a pu faire
respecter le principe de libre passage
inoffensif dans les eaux internationales
puisque cette frégate a traversé le
détroit de Taïwan comme prévu comme cela
avait été conçu et planifié il se trouve
que c'était au moment où la Chine a
procédé des manœuvres
qui ont marqué les esprit mais nous nous
ont pas empêchés de faire respecter le
droit international et puis dans toute
cette zone adopacifique nous renforçons
également nos partenaires et
stratégiques avec l'Inde avec le Japon
avec
l'Indonésie et d'autres monsieur le
Président vous avez évoqué l'Inde nous
avons un partenariat stratégique qui
remonte à 25 ans et qui produit de
nombreux effets notamment sur le plan de
la défense et de la sécurité des
coopérations industrielle mais pas
seulement et nous avons l'ambition
d'aller au-delà avec l'un des de
renouveler ce partenariat à l'occasion
de la visite à Paris du Premier ministre
maudit puisqu'il sera l'invité d'honneur
des 14 juillet et cette occasion devrait
avec le président de la République
tracer les grandes lignes du futur
partenariat
accru et couvrant plus de domaines après
la célébration de ces 25 ans
le coeur de notre approche de la résumé
en quelques mots vis-à-vis début de
cette région
ça n'est pas
de proposer une
troisième voie
l'expression n'a jamais été utilisée je
crois par les autorités françaises en
tout cas pas dans ce cadre il nous est
arrivé dans le passé de l'évoquer sur
les questions sociaux économiques mais
pas dans le cadre géostratégique nous ne
sommes pas écho distance entre les uns
et les autres en tout cas certainement
pas entre les Etats-Unis d'Amérique qui
sont nos alliés et nos amis notre plus
vieille allié dit-on et la Chine mais le
président de la République a indiqué
clairement la France
refuse et elle a raison c'est son
intérêt refuse que se mettent en place
progressivement et parfois
involontairement une logique de
confrontation entre les blocs qui ne
serait quasimenter les tensions et
alimenter les risques d'escalade les
tensions sont déjà suffisamment
visibles dans la zone donc notre
objectif est tout simplement de je l'ai
dit renforcer la liberté de choix de nos
partenaires renforcer leur capacité de
résilience tout comme tout comme nous
renforçons notre propre autonomie
stratégique celle de la France et celle
de l'Union européenne et je crois que
tout président de la République
française est attachée à cette capacité
d'indépendance de notre pays
j'en viens et j'aborderai en abordant la
deuxième grande transformation que le
ministère en temps mené quelques
situations aussi que vous avez évoquées
cette deuxième demande du Président de
la République cette deuxième orientation
cette deuxième transformation elle
consiste à investir résolument le champ
de l'influence c'est une autre priorité
alors bien sûr le premier pilier de
notre influence c'est l'Europe parce que
une robe forte et la condition de notre
indépendance c'est le sens de l'agenda
de souveraineté que nous portons je vais
là le lien avec ce que je viens de
d'évoquer dans le cadre indopacifique
et c'est un agenda que les 27 ont
clairement affiché tous ensemble ça
n'est pas seulement un agenda français
c'est un agenda européen puisque au
sommet de Versailles il y a un peu plus
d'un an la Corse est fait entre chef
d'État ou gouvernement de couvrir tous
les volets de cet agenda de souveraineté
et de le mettre en oeuvre ce que nous
faisons ce qu'ils font depuis donc un
peu plus d'un an d'abord une robe de la
défense qui monte en puissance et qui
progressivement se dotent des moyens de
ses ambitions c'est notamment le sens
des livraisons de munitions et de
matériel à l'Ukraine c'est aussi
l'éloignement des dépendances que
certains pays européens avaient à
l'endroit de la Russie notamment dans le
domaine des hydrocarbures de la France
n'était pas dans la situation de
l'Allemagne vous le savez ou d'autres
pays mais il faut souligner que l'Union
européenne a su en moins d'un an
se détacher de ses dépendances et puis
c'est aussi par exemple la préparation
d'un onzième paquet de sanctions contre
l'agresseur russe de façon à peser sur
son effort de guerre et limiter les
financements ou l'accès des matériels et
à des technologies qui lui permettent de
continuer son effort de guerre nous
voulons l'entraver et peser sur celui-ci
par ailleurs
je voudrais souligner que l'Union
européenne a pris un tournant qui était
encore peut-être
inimaginable il y a quelques années
parler de politique industrielle
européenne il y a quelques années et
notamment à une époque où j'ai assumé
d'autres fonctions ministérielles
étaient
impossible voire même choqué un certain
nombre de nos partenaires
ou d'autres à Bruxelles et bien nous
mettons en place une véritable politique
industrielle qui se mettra au service
des entreprises européennes qui parient
sur la transition verte et numérique
avec un système puissant d'aide et
d'accélération des mécanismes d'aide et
donc une assez profonde modification
de la part de
la machine européenne qui revoit les
règles qui étaient les siennes
le repas a pris conscience de ses
dépendances excessives dans certains
secteurs et ses forces de les réduire
depuis l'énergie jusqu'au produit de
santé
des copines des rieslings mais vous
connaissez le débat nous voulons réduire
les dépendances lorsqu'elles étaient
excessives et vis-à-vis de tout le monde
de façon renforcer l'autonomie de
l'Europe donc énergie santé
semi-conducteur
matière première batterie et l'annonce
la semaine dernière dans le cadre de
shoes France de l'implantation d'une
super
usine du taïwanais prologium à Dunkerque
Dunkerque a reçu beaucoup
d'investissements ces derniers temps a
été un signal positif un signal fort des
bonnes nouvelles que nous avons pu
porter en termes de transformation
d'économie du pays vis-à-vis des
investisseurs qui répondent présent
cette édition était la sixième édition
de chausse France a été une édition
record en termes d'investissement
recueilli comme en termes d'emploi
puisque vous l'avez vu on en est à 13
milliards d'euros d'investissements
étrangers avec à la clé la création de
8000 emplois donc une édition record qui
fait de souffrance maintenant à
dispositif bien établie et qui confirme
la place de pays européens le plus
attractif pour les investissements
étrangers pour ce qui concerne la France
pour la quatrième fois de suite c'est
bien le signe que les investisseurs
voient une France qui s'est réformée et
qui est un pays où il faut investir
parce qu'il est utile d'y investir la
France se réapproprie également
sa politique commerciale et sans
remonter à son ouverture qui est un peu
sa marque de fabrique l'Europe est né en
lançant la mise en commun dans certains
de produits puis le marché commun donc
c'est vraiment notre ADN mais en
complément elle ne l'avait pas fait
jusqu'ici c'était une erreur elle s'est
dotée tout récemment d'instruments de
réciprocité et d'un ciment de protection
anti-coercession directeur dans les
vocable bruxellois qui était
indispensable pour contrer certaines
pratiques déloyales
ces transformations doivent être
poursuivies dans le dans un schéma
d'ensemble et nous avons pu mettre sur
pied maintenant une véritable doctrine
de sécurité économique européenne je
vous renvoie là
ce sont des sujets intéressants à ce que
le président de la République a exposé
par exemple de façon très structurée le
11 avril dernier dans son discours de la
devant
une
assemblée
nombreuse et compositeurs en dehors de
ces entretiens bilatéraux officiel
une Europe forte et j'en ai bientôt
terminé monsieur le Président et
mesdames dessinatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est aussi un rempart face au
turbulences international c'est un pôle
de stabilité donc nous en avons besoin
j'évoquais le rôle de l'Union européenne
en Arménie et en Azerbaïdjan mais notre
diplomatie travaille sur d'autres volets
pour assurer cette stabilité et ancrer
des pays dans le jeu international
avec un plein respect de la règle de
droit comme nous le souhaitons je parle
notamment là de la politique
d'élargissement dans ce cadre nous
réaffirmons que l'horizon des Balkans
occidentaux comme celui de l'Ukraine et
celui de la Moldavie c'est bien le
modèle européen et non celui des
puissances stabilisatrices il faut les
aider à progresser vers nous donc là il
faut les aider à faire des réformes nous
ne leur disons et nous ne leur disons
extrêmement clairement et puis je Ie pas
non plus le rôle très positif que joue
la communauté politique européenne autre
initiative française
nouvelle édition donc je l'ai dit dans
moins de deux semaines
en Moldavie qui offre dans un format
allant au-delà de l'Union européenne
possibilité de dialogue politique
flexible c'est apprécié des chefs d'État
haute-gouvernement nous avions même pu
voir souvenez-vous la première ministre
britannique participer la première
édition de la communauté politique
européenne
notre diplomatie européenne continuera
de se déployer pour faire avancer ces
quelques grands chantiers que j'ai cités
et bien d'autres nous savons qu'il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour mettre en
oeuvre intégralement l'agenda de
Versailles pour consolider la base
industrielle européenne même si nous
avons marqué beaucoup de points ces
dernières années pour faire progresser
encore la base technologique de défense
et pour faire progresser tous les enjeux
de régulation et de compétitivité dans
le domaine numérique mais aussi dans la
défense de nos valeurs parfois ça se
joue aussi à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne comme vous le savez un mot
pour
terminer sur l'Afrique
au Mali et au Burkina Faso mais aussi
dans dans d'autres pays du continent oui
ne faisons face à une augmentation
extrêmement inquiétante des
manipulations de la formation qui
permettent notamment de diffuser
insidieusement et un bon compte je veux
dire par là avec très peu de moyens et
des budgets relativement faibles
un discours anti-français contraire à la
vérité qui peut qui peut influer
certains esprits et au-delà de cette
diffusion et de ses discours
permet
de déstabiliser en réalité certains
états alors
nous avons dû en tenir compte et nous
nous sommes réorganisés pour faire face
à ce défi dans l'esprit de ce nouveau
partenariat que le Président de la
République
veut nouer avec l'Afrique et construit
pas à pas depuis six ans depuis le
discours de Ouagadougou de 2017 et qu'il
a tenu d'ailleurs réaffirmer renouveler
tout récemment dans un grand discours
fin février elle est Lisée concrètement
nous avons ainsi
je parle du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères là augmenter nos
capacités de communication de veille et
de riposte sur les réseaux sociaux à
Paris comme dans nos ambassades en
augmentant un petit peu nos moyens et
nous allons pouvoir poursuivre grâce à
ce schéma plus réelle qui a été annoncé
par le président de la République c'est
une priorité qui avait été clairement
identifiée dans le cadre des États
généraux un travail avait déjà été
entrepris mais nous avons pris des
décisions à la très rapidement avec de
bons résultats si sont capables
d'identifier plus vite évidemment les
les tentatives de déstabilisation et la
diffusion de fausses informations bien
nous pouvons réagir plus vite risque
plus vite dans le cadre d'une mission
qui est ouverte qui a un autre c'est à
nous
respectons bien évidemment les principes
et le droit ai-je besoin de le préciser
mais nous cherchons aussi au delà de
s'éveille et série postes à améliorer
notre image en travaillant davantage en
profondeur avec les sociétés africaines
le président de la République parle
souvent de l'indécité de développer une
plus grande intimité avec les sociétés
africaines
le Conseil présidentiel du développement
qui s'est réuni il y a quelques jours
permettra d'ailleurs d'avancer en
mettant en avant vous l'avez une logique
maintenant
d'aide par objectif et non plus par zone
géographique prioritaire même si nous
garderons évidemment à l'intérieur de
l'aide au développement dans ses
partenariats une très claire priorité
très claire priorité donnée à l'Afrique
mais il est clair qu'on doit parler
encore
plus à davantage de monde aux jeunes aux
jeunes entrepreneurs à la société civile
tous ceux qui feront l'Afrique de demain
parler aux opposants nous le faisons
nous le faisons peut-être pas d'hier que
nous ambassades ou nous-mêmes avant des
contacts avec les uns des autres mais
clairement il faut le faire encore plus
investir beaucoup plus sur eux tout en
en développement ce que l'on n'avait pas
fait suffisamment également qui est
d'utiliser nos diaspora les diaspora de
ce pays présentent en France qui sont
très souvent de bons relais des passeurs
privilégiés entre les uns les autres et
puis le renforçons aussi nos vecteurs
d'influence auprès de public
prioritaires je parle là de tout ce que
nous faisons en terme de partenariat
universitaire ou de formation
professionnelle
nous participons au débat d'idées nous
soutenons les industries culturelles et
créatives d'un nouveau champ de
coopération les sportifs les start-up
chaque fois que je me déplace dans les
pays africains je vois qu'il y a des
jeunes
impeccablement bien formés
innovant qui ont des idées que nous
devons aider davantage à progresser à
merger ça va aussi d'ailleurs ce que je
dis en adopacifique où nous avons décidé
d'accueillir plus d'étudiants et plus de
scientifiques et de mener de grands
projets bilatéraux à l'échelle
indopacifique notamment grâce à
l'Australie à l'Union européenne nous
mèneront des actions auprès de plusieurs
des petits pays du Pacifique
et enfin je sais que vous y êtes
sensible
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
l'échelle du monde entier notre
politique de visa
mérite d'être
renouvelée mais de retrouver une
planification
après trois années de trois années
pardon de pandémie et une reprise très
forte des demandes de visa qui se sont
traduits par demande en hausse ajoutez
une certaine
désorganisation parfois nos services de
visa donc tout en menant une politique
migratoire rigoureuse la politique de
visa elle vise à faciliter l'accès à nos
pays elle est aussi une politique
d'attractivité
et donc d'accueil de public cible de
cette politique d'influence que je
décrivais universitaire jeune d'avenir
jeunes scientifique ou scientifiques un
rapport sur la politique des visas m'a
été remis tout récemment le rapport
Hermelin s'appuyant sur les deux
inspections générales du ministère de
l'Intérieur et du ministère de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères sur cette
base
je pense que nous pourrons prendre
encore des mesures complémentaires pour
l'améliorer j'en viens à la troisième
transformation mais j'avais beaucoup
plus vite prendre pleinement le tournant
des enjeux globaux je veux évoquer le
climat évidemment puisque le dernier
rapport du GIEC la rappeler de façon
très claire les conséquences du
changement climatique sont là et elles
sont brutales certaines sont
irréversibles toutes ne le sont pas et
en tout cas il est encore temps d'agir
et donc il faut agir pour éviter le pire
et ça demande pas se résigner
à l'heure du bilan de la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord de Paris qui sera fait lors
de la Coop 28 donc la prochaine au semi
rarabes Unis nos efforts collectifs
doivent être à la hauteur du défi
climatique la France joue un rôle majeur
elle est à l'initiative et c'est ainsi
que le Président de la République a
décidé d'accueillir à Paris les 22 et 23
juin un sommet qui réunira le secrétaire
général des Nations unies les
institutions financières internationales
beaucoup d'autres organisations
internationales les gouvernements des
acteurs de la société civile pour
sceller les grands principes d'un
nouveau pacte financier mondial face aux
fractures on le voit grandissante et
préoccupante dangereuse entre le Nord et
le Sud de façon sur la base du consensus
qui pourra être dégagé à la fin du mois
de juin de poursuivre le travail tous
ensemble de façon
à répondre aux besoins des pays en
développement d'une meilleure manière en
complémentarité entre les uns et les
autres et nous nous adresserons en
particulier
aux besoins des pays les plus
vulnérables
toute sa part je ne veux pas
manquer de saisir l'audition de cette
audition pour rappeler que la France est
désormais le quatrième pourvoyeur
mondial d'aide au développement
c'est un bel effort qui a été fait ces
dernières années
nous avons pu le constater lors du
Conseil présidentiel du développement
que j'évoquais où nous avons par
ailleurs
acté un certain nombre d'axes de
modernisation de cette aide vous l'avez
vu peut-être dans le communiqué publique
qui a suivi la réunion du conseil et
l'effort de mobilisation de la jeunesse
que j'évoquais en fait partie a été très
bien reçu en particulier la création de
3000 postes d'experts et volontaires
internationaux sur tous ces enjeux d'ici
à 2027 là si on résonne sur le même
schéma plus réelle notre pays
accueillera si je parle des affaires
globales la
tenue à partir du 27 mai donc tout
prochainement des négociations contre la
pollution plastique dans le but de
conclure dans quelques années un grand
traité international sur la pollution
plastique qui est un fléau en
particulier
dans les océans où il fait des ravages
sur la faune et puis nous avons déjà
commencé de préparer la Conférence des
Nations Unies sur les océans qui
soutiendra à Nice en juin 2025 et donc
pour rester en initiative
obtenir des résultats aussi sur tous ces
enjeux globaux il faut une diplomatie
qui a des moyens qui a des hommes et des
femmes et qui a des moyens budgétaires
quatrième transformation
mais j'irai encore plus vite
l'amélioration des services rendus à nos
ressortissants à l'étranger je rappelle
toujours et je veux rappeler que la
France est l'un des pays au monde sinon
le pays au monde qui fait le plus pour
fournir des services publics de qualité
et accessible à ce ressortissants mais
nous continuons d'innover en poursuivant
de grands chantiers de modernisation le
vote par internet il s'est révélé
même si le Conseil constitutionnel a dû
sanctionner les déficiences non pas de
notre service public mais des
fournisseurs d'accès qui n'avaient pas
permis à certains SMS d'arriver le vote
par Internet a été un grand succès il a
permis de recueillir les gagnants les
trois quarts des suffrages exprimés lors
des législatives pour ce qui concerne
étrangers on l'a vu également lors des
législatives partielles il y a quelques
semaines nous développons aussi la
modernisation de l'accès au service
consulaire à distance vous l'envoie
postale des passeports et nous devons et
nous allons poursuivre dans cette voie
pour chercher à capitaliser pleinement
sur les bénéfices de la
dématérialisation des procédures et
dégager ainsi du temps pour offrir dans
nos postes consulaires un meilleur
service à ceux de nos compatriotes qui
auraient besoin de s'y rendre
voilà en quelques mots mesdames les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le Président ce que je voulais
vous dire en prenant appui sur les
quatre axes de transformation du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères mais ces axes m'ont permis je
crois d'évoquer même
brièvement les principaux points que
vous avez évoqués dans votre
intervention en déminéraires monsieur le
Président à l'exception peut-être de la
Turquie donc je me sens l'obligation
d'en parler en disant que le résultat du
premier tour et ce qu'il est les
législatives ont été succès majorité
absolue pour le parti au pouvoir allier
un parti un peu plus nationaliste encore
et un second tour pour le président
r2hane qui est une nouveauté il n'en
n'avait pas l'habitude même s'il est en
bonne position
pour
aborder le
le deuxième et dernier tour j'ajoute que
d'après les premières éléments transmis
par la mission d'observation des
élections de l'OSCE le scrutin se
déroulé dans de bonnes conditions en
tout cas de bonne condition formelle le
cadre juridique pouvant faire l'objet
d'observation et comme vous le savez sur
les libertés publiques mais tout ceci a
été dit et même écrit par la Mission
voilà monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre de ce très
large tour d'horizon
gêne néanmoins il me reste il me reste
un certain nombre de questions on va les
prendre ces questions minutes
à moitié Joël guerriot merci Président
Madame le Ministre c'est toujours un
exercice difficile que le faire un tour
d'horizon d'un monde très agité je vais
faire un focus et un seul puisque il est
important de tenir un peu nos tendres de
parole
je voudrais faire un focus sur Taïwan
vous l'avez voca de reprise dans votre
votre intervention aujourd'hui les
la Chine semble avoir un discours un peu
plus un peu en recul par rapport au
passé sur la question de taiwanaise
est-ce que c'est lié à la pression
internationale ou bien lié à une autre
stratégie de la Chine pour y revenir un
peu plus tard et de manière plus
rigoureuse voilà ma question mais et
surtout dans ce dans ce dans cette
brèche qui semble s'ouvrir est-ce que
l'on peut pas revenir sur une demande
qui a été fait par plusieurs pays dont
nous-mêmes à travers une résolution que
nous avions commencé au Sénat pour faire
en sorte que Taïwan puisse accéder à
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé à
Interpol à l'Organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale en tant
qu'observateur puisque il s'agit
d'identité dont les statues permettent
de participer sans pour autant être un
état et sans mettre en cause les droits
des États membres donc est-ce que l'on
peut pas revenir sur cette question car
je pense que c'est vraiment totalement
injuste que une un état de cet envergure
enfin du moins un pays de cet envergure
puisse être mis à l'écart et surtout
après les apports qu'il a eu dans le
cadre de la covid dont il a montré à
quel point il était en capacité de
mettre en place une gestion tout à fait
remarquable
merci Olivier
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre en marge de l'opération de
chausse France le premier succès cité
par le chef de l'État lors de son
interview télévisé lundi dernier a été
la décision donc de l'entreprise
taïwanaise prologium qui investit 5,2
milliards d'euros en France et prévoit
de créer 3000 emplois à Dunkerque le
président de prologium déclare dans un
hebdomadaire combien l'implication
personnelle du président de la
République a été déterminante dans la
décision de sa société je me réjouis des
résultats des efforts entrepris pour
notre attractivité depuis 2017 puisque
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui a initié des
sommets que d'autres pays cherchent à
copier désormais vous l'avez dit la
France est depuis quatre ans au premier
rang européen pour accueillir les
investissements étrangers s'agissant de
Taïwan vous avez rappelé depuis Tokyo
madame la ministre et je vous en
remercie la politique constante et sans
ambiguïté de la France en faveur de la
paix et de la stabilité dans le détroit
et proposer à toute modification
ultime unilatérale du statu quo la Chine
elle affirme sa volonté de s'emparer par
la force s'il le faut de Taïwan dont
elle revendique la souveraineté au nom
de la réunification nationale fermer les
guillemets la zone est au centre d'une
concurrence géopolitique très intensive
preuve en sont notamment les tensions
croissantes autour de territoire et de
zones maritimes contestées par la Chine
qui affiche son expansionnisme face à
ses voisins la situation dans
l'adopacifique n'a jamais été aussi
dangereuse depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale a déclaré l'ambassadrice
d'Australie en France lors d'une
conférence à Paris les parlementaires
français se rendent régulièrement à
Taïwan pour renforcer notre relation
bilatérale avec Lille vous le savez qui
pointe à la vingtième place pour son PIB
des ministres européens se déplacent
également régulièrement sur l'île et en
profite pour saluer la vigueur de cette
économie et de sa démocratie cela fait
de nombreuses années que l'île n'a pas
été visitée par un membre du
gouvernement français compte tenu de la
hauteur de l'investissement taïwanais
dans l'Hexagone est-ce que vous ou le
ministre Olivier belge en charge du
commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
des Français à l'étranger avait prévu de
vous rendre prochainement à Taïwan afin
de marquer notre reconnaissance pour
cette marque de confiance et approfondir
notre relation bilatérale je vous
remercie merci Philippe folio
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre tout d'abord une remarque et
puis une question
la remarque nous allons avec le
président et les membres de la
délégation de l'Assemblée parlementaire
de l'OTAN à Luxembourg pour la session
de printemps de notre assemblée et très
honnêtement dans le droit de ce que
disait le président et de sa remarque
tout à l'heure je pense que c'est
certainement dommage que la France
annonce une formation de pilote
ukrainien et dans le même temps ne va
pas tout de suite jusqu'au bout de la
logique notamment la fourniture de 12
mirages 2016 qui sont actuellement et
qui dorment dans des hangars il serait
certainement plus utile sur sur le
théâtre ukrainien ma question madame
malaministre a trait à un continent qui
malheureusement est souvent pas
considéré comme prioritaire par notre
diplomatie je pense à l'Amérique latine
avec quatre de nos collègues nous sommes
rendus en mission mi-avril et plus
particulièrement au Brésil nous avons du
reste visité la base navale d'itagai et
avec les autorités brésiliennes nous
avons pu voir combien étaient fortes les
relations
franco-brésiliennes en matière donc
d'équipements sous-marins mais au-delà
de ça j'ai une question très précise à
vous poser il va y avoir un sommet de
l'Amazonie début août madame la ministre
est-ce que le Président de la République
se rendra ce sommet parce que c'est un
enjeu important
au regard de ceux qui sera décidé mais
aussi ne l'oublions pas parce que la
France est puissance d'Amérique du Sud
au travers de la Guyane et que dans ce
cadre-là nous avons une responsabilité
toute particulière ensuite je voudrais
vous poser une question plus spécifique
par rapport à un certain nombre d'enjeux
relatifs au plateau guyanais
et notamment par rapport au Guyana
le le Koweït obtenu son indépendance en
1961 7 ans après en 1968 la France
ouvrit une ambassade
le Qatar et le Bahreïn ont obtenu leur
indépendance en 1971 et un an plus tard
en 1972 la France ouvrait une ambassade
le Brunet obtenait son indépendance en
1984 et 7 ans plus tard en 1981
la France ouvrit une ambassade le Guyane
est indépendant depuis 1966 et 57 ans
après nous n'avons toujours pas
d'ambassade alors nous avons un agent
détaché de l'ambassade du Suriname qui
fait un travail du reste remarquable
nous avons pu le constater sur sur le
terrain et on nous dit qu'il y aurait la
perspective d'ouvrir un bureau permanent
peut-être au mois de septembre mais ceci
n'est pas satisfaisant n'est pas la
hauteur des enjeux pourquoi parce que
d'importantes réserves de pétrole ont
été trouvées au Guyana et ce pays qui
est jusqu'à présent un des plus pauvres
numérique du Sud va d'ici
5 ans être 5 à 10 ans le pays le plus
riche d'Amérique du Sud avec d'énormes
marchés et donc un certain nombre de
difficultés y compris et notamment pour
les chefs d'entreprise donc du Guyana
qui voudrait se rendre en France qui
sont obligés d'aller dans le pays voisin
le Suriname pour chercher un visa et
tout ceci n'est assurément pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et respectable et et
donc en fonction de ces éléments madame
la ministre pouvez-vous nous donner des
assurances et des garanties pour une
ouverture très rapide et très prochaine
donc d'une ambassade donc à georgestone
la capitale du Guyana d'autant plus que
au-delà des pays voisins d'Amérique du
Sud les quatre autres membres permanents
du Conseil de sécurité les États-Unis la
Chine la Russie et la Grande-Bretagne
ont une ambassade et la France est le
seul pays donc membre du Conseil de
sécurité à ne pas avoir d'ambassade et
d'autant plus que si nous avions cette
opportunité d'ouvrir une ambassade nous
serions le premier pays de l'Union
européenne à ouvrir une ambassade même
si l'Union européenne une délégation
dans ce dans ce pays alors donc je crois
que c'est un enjeu qui passe peut-être
en dessous les radars madame la ministre
mais qui est un enjeu important pour le
plateau guyanais et rappelons que la
France est quasi voisine du Guyana au
travers donc de la Guyane française
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre d'enjeux
économiques migratoires mais aussi par
rapport à l'environnement à la forêt aux
ressources haliotiques et aux
hydrocarbures qui sont communs à
l'ensemble des pays du plateau guyanais
dont la France
le président Cambon ayant confié donc
l'intérim j'ai passé la parole au
président Patriat merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la ministre pour
votre exposé brillant sur situation que
vous avez évoquée dans les différents
conflits je voudrais une peau poser une
question d'un ordre tout à fait
différent parce que de son côté je veux
dire à l'occasion de la Journée mondiale
de la lutte contre l'homophobie la
transphobie et la biphobie la France a
réitéré son engagement ferme en faveur
de la dépanner dépénalisation
universelle de l'homosexualité de la
défense des droits et des personnes
LGBTI de son côté la France avait lancé
un plan national d'action contre pour
l'égalité contre la haine et les
discriminations en accompagnant les
efforts de la société civile dans les
instants dans les enceintes
multilatérales
ce n'est pas le cas pour tout le monde
encore beaucoup de personnes et LGBTQI
continue de connaître la violence à
persécution les discours est nuls la
justice voir le meurtre pur et simple
chacun agression contre les personnes
LGB lui LGBTQ est une agression contre
les droits humains et les valeurs qui
nous sont chères alors c'est pourquoi
madame la ministre je voudrais savoir
quelle est la stratégie diplomatique de
la France est plus largement l'action
internationale prévue pour lutter contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie et la
biphobie
merci André catholin s'il vous plaît
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous l'avez au cours de
votre exposé évoqué plusieurs fois la
question de la politique d'influence et
naturellement on peut que se référer à
un aspect très important qui est celui
de la diplomatie culturelle
ma question est en deux points le
premier point nous avons reçu ces
derniers jours et encore juste avant
cette audition plusieurs parlementaires
représentants de Moldavie notamment la
délégation moldave que nous avons reçue
il y a une heure à la commission des
affaires européennes nous demandait une
aide une assistance de la France en
matière de lutte contre la
désinformation la propagande la
manipulation de l'information et les
narratifs agressifs de la Russie sur
leur territoire vous êtes pas sans le
savoir il y a eu des élections
gouvernes naturales comme on dit en
gagawasi que le résultat fait l'objet
ces derniers heures de très très vives
tensions
l'influence en matière médiatique russe
était très notamment sur les populations
russophone malgré une interdiction des
chaînes les la propagande continue via
des réseaux sociaux sans que le
gouvernement moldave parvienne à la
contenir et ils ont l'intention de la
dans le cadre normatif de créer un
centre de communication stratégique et
ils appellent notre pays en grande
partie au secours parce qu'ils savent
que nous sommes confrontés à des choses
équivalentes en France mais aussi en
Afrique le deuxième point toujours sur
la politique d'influence culturelle vous
avez eu un entretien il y a quelques
jours avec monsieur kingang le ministre
des affaires étrangères de la République
populaire de Chine il était contenu de
renforcer là encore tous les éléments de
la diplomatie je dirais culturelle avec
une reprise sans entrave des mobilités
entre les deux pays notamment concernant
les communautés d'affaires les touristes
et les étudiants auteur il y a un an et
demi dans rapport sur les influences et
les ingérences dans le milieu académique
et un
les ingérences extra-européennes je me
suis inquiété avec tous les membres de
la de ce groupe de travail de la
particularité de la communauté studiante
chinoise aujourd'hui extrêmement sous
contrôle du Parti communiste ou du front
uni les tentatives souvent d'intrusion
dans des aides RR et des pressions qui
sont aussi exercées auprès des
universités sur les sujets qui sont
traités il s'agit de pas parler et
parler de Taïwan des Ouigours du Tibet
ou de Hong Kong comment entendons-nous
développer ces relations mais mettre en
place un système de contrôle tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui en œuvre en Australie ou
au Japon pour que on suive les activités
de ces étudiants qu'on se garantissent
de leur véritable identité de leur
parcours et de leurs appartenances le
Japon quand ils reçoivent des étudiants
chinois les suit pendant deux ou trois
ans pour voir si les travaux qui
publient sont véritablement des travaux
universitaires ou des reprises
d'informations qui sera obtenues donc
nous attendons et en tant
qu'administrateur de Campus France nous
attendons des sécurités sur cette
réouverture qui semblerait vouloir être
massive de d'étudier en chinois venant
en France je vous remercie
si vous le voulez bien je vous
proposerai de répondre à cette première
série de questions je vous remercie
mais merci beaucoup monsieur sénateur
une première série de questions je
remercie à tous les sénateurs
ont posé des questions intéressantes si
vous le permettez je vais en grande
partie regrouper
la question du sénatargario celle du
centre Cadic qui portait sur Taïwan ou
quoi que j'ajouterai un point
particulier et spécifique à la question
du sénateur caddic sur le Taiwan je
crois que les choses ont été
suffisamment
dites et répétés y compris par moi-même
à merci d'y avoir fait illusion la
France je devais résumer les choses et
favorable au statu quo et défavorable
certainement à toute modification
unilatérale de ce setup évidemment
encore davantage s'il devait être
imaginé de se faire par la force et
d'une façon générale elle est
défavorable à la montée des tensions
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
dernières semaines en particulier
conduit à nous exprimer pour qu'il soit
clair pour les uns les autres que ça
n'était pas une situation positive nous
assurons par ailleurs le respect des
grands principes du droit international
et pour ce qui concerne la liberté de
circulation dans les trois Taïwan je
crois que nous sommes le seul pays à
l'avoir fait dans ce moment particulier
et avec ce message qui était
parfaitement compris des uns et des
autres et donc si le contexte est plus
calme qu'il y a quelques semaines
si cela devait pour partie être dû à
l'action de la France nous nous en
réjouirions les relations avec Taïwan
sont de qualité sont anciennes elles
sont en développement de surcroît mais
ils sont économiques et culturelles
elles sont aussi parlementaires vous le
savez bien monsieur le sénateur mais ce
ne sont pas des relations diplomatiques
alors pour venir aux deux questions
précises qui m'ont été posées nous
sommes favorables d'ailleurs ça se
pratique nous sommes favorables à la
présence de Taïwan dans un certain
nombre d'organisants international
spécialisés là où sa présence a ou
aurait une valeur ajoutée j'ajoute
monsieur sénateur que c'est le cas à mes
yeux de l'OMS
tout en répétant que cette présence de
Taïwan dans des organisations
internationales spécialisées n'importe
pas reconnaissance comme État la 76ème
assemblée de l'OMS est en cours et
sachez que nous avons exprimé notre
accord pour que Taiwan soit étroitement
associé au travaux de l'organisation je
ne vois pas qu'il faille faire une
exception ce principe général que je
rappelle monsieur sénateur Cathy me
demandait si je comptais effectuer en
tant que ministre en tout cas une visite
à Taïwan ou y envoyer un des ministres
du pôle ça n'est pas prévu monsieur
sénateur donc non je ne le prévois pas
et j'ajouterais même que je ne le pense
pas approprié voulant voir dans la
politique équilibrée qui est la nôtre et
qui produit quelques résultats un
meilleur moyen d'action pour assurer le
respect du droit international et ça
dirait l'apaisement qui est bien
nécessaire
lorsqu'on parle de cette zone
monsieur le sénateur folio vous avez
évoqué plusieurs sujets je reviens très
brièvement sur l'Ukraine et la formation
des pilotes
je m'étais efforcé de souligner voire
même de faire comprendre la différence
entre formation de base et formation
ensuite sur telle ou tel type d'appareil
donc il peut y avoir un intérêt et en
tout cas c'est l'opinion
des autorités ukrainiennes à faire
assurer une formation de base par
plusieurs pays sans que cela préjuge du
type d'appareil qui pourrait qui
pourrait conditionner être livré et
utilisé ensuite par l'Ukraine
en tronc commun si je veux dire j'espère
être plus clair cette fois-ci avec le
Brésil
avec lequel pays émergent gamerge et
avec lequel on a un partenariat
stratégique de qualité redevenu de
qualité maintenant que les élections ont
porté à nouveau le président Lola à la
tête de ce pays nous cooperons bien dans
un certain nombre de domaines y compris
dans le domaine
naval et de défense puisque vous faisiez
allusion lorsque j'étais
en visite officielle au Brésil au tout
début du mois de février le président
Lola qui avait la gentillesse de me
recevoir m'avait en effet transmis
l'invitation qu'il adressait à la France
de venir assister au sommet Amazonie
prévue je crois le 6 et le 7 août et
donc je ne peux pas à ce stade vous
répondre pour le président de la
République mais je peux vous assurer en
tout cas que la France sera représentée
bien évidemment
enfin pour le Guyana
nous connaissons bien la situation en
particulier
la difficulté qu'il y a devoir se
déplacer pour faire les démarches
relatives au visa c'est bien identifié
mais je ne peux pas vous donner
l'assurance que nous allons
ouvrir une ambassade ni au Guyane
d'ailleurs si nos moyens ont été
renforcés ou sont appelés à l'être pour
autant que le Parlement valide les
propositions qui lui seront faites il
faudrait bien plus pour que nous en
soyons à ouvrir des ambassades après
avoir dû réduire le réseau consulaire
notamment
fortement dans les deux dernières
décennies mais je vous remercie de ce
plaidoyer qui était un beau plaidoyer on
y pensera peut-être pour l'avenir si nos
moyens nous le permettent
les budgets sont annuels mais cette
sénateurs que vous dire
il peut y avoir des schémas de
déploiement il peut y avoir des schémas
de redéploiement d'effectif je veux dire
avec trois quatre personnes on peut
faire fonctionner une ambassade et il y
a des enjeux qui seront des enjeux
économiques j'ai pas redire ce que j'ai
dit mais voilà je trouve et je pense je
m'exprime aussi au nom de mes quatre
collègues qui étaient avec moi nous
trouvons que que c'est assurément très
dommage voilà et que si il y avait un
moment sur lequel il fallait sortir
d'une d'une logique j'allais un peu
administrative pour aller vers une
logique politique et de développement et
bien c'est bien là il y avait un symbole
c'est dommage j'entends bien ma logique
n'est pas administrative mais pratiquée
pratique après avoir perdu plus de 20%
de ses effectifs sur les dernières
années ce que aucun autre ministère n'a
subi nous devons consolider renforcer
non pas des habillé Pierre pour habiller
Paul si les moyens le permettaient je
ferai la première heureuse de pouvoir
ouvrir des ambassades peut-être là
peut-être dans la dopacifique dans le
Pacifique nous en avons trois et qui
sont de toutes petites ambassades mais
ces sénateur patria vous m'avez
interrogé opportunément compte tenu de
la journée internationale de lutte
contre l'homophobie la biphobie la
transformation
sur ce que nous faisons sur l'action de
la France pour faire progresser le
respect des droits en la matière et donc
dans le cas d'une politique qui est
générale et à laquelle notre pays je
crois fortement attaché d'assurer
l'universalité des droits de l'homme car
les droits de l'homme sont universel il
faut le réaffirmer en particulier au
moment où
d'autres pays ont tendance à diffuser
une autre vision des choses et bien nous
sommes attachés à l'égalité entre tous
et à ceux entre les hommes et les femmes
mais à ceux des droits des personnes
lgptées plus qui ne sont pas encore
pleinement respectées c'est loin d'être
le cas dans le monde
j'ai demandé au réseau diplomatique de
se mobiliser et c'est la première fois
qu'il est activé de cette façon une note
diplomatique comme on dit une note
d'instruction
est partie hier à l'ensemble de nos
postes diplomatiques et consulaires et
c'est la première fois que nous
demandons à tous nos postes de se
mobiliser en tenant compte des
particularités locales bien évidemment
parce qu'il sera absurde de ne pas le
faire mais en inscrivant très clairement
dans leur plan d'action
la
progression du respect du droit des
personnes LGBT et également pour
à la dépénalisation de l'homosexualité
certains pays considérant encore qu'il
s'agit d'un comportement qui mérite des
sanctions pénales nous avons nommé un
ambassadeur qui est chargé de ces enjeux
peut-être l'avez-vous déjà reçu
Jean-Marc Berton il est à l'oeuvre il a
un plan d'action que j'ai approuvé et il
se il a tout un programme de déplacement
notamment pour se rendre dans
des pays qui sont en passe
d'adopter des lois homophobes aux
liberticides ou qui l'ont fait j'ai
aussi demandé un travail sur les
financements qui permettraient même des
petits financements de soutenir partout
dans le monde celles et ceux qui
défendent et qui promovent le respect de
ses droits et puis j'ajoute parce que
il faut hélas aborder aussi ces
questions dans le contexte de la guerre
russe en Ukraine que
cette guerre s'accompagne d'un narratif
sur les valeurs
je vais mettre des guillemets pour ne
pas être mal comprise d'épée de
l'Occident on a encore entendu dans la
bouche du président Poutine lors de son
allocution du 9 mai ou sur une
présentation
incroyable enfin narrative qui cheminent
qui présente les droits des personnes
LGBT comme voilà de prétendu valeur
occidentale je crois que les êtres
humains sont égaux partis dans le monde
ou qu'ils soient et donc il est bien
regrettable que la Russie se fasse le
porte-drapeau manifeste et actif de
cette homophobie rétrograde donc nous
situons aussi notre action dans ce cadre
monsieur le sénateur gatelin
sur
d'une façon générale
l'influence de
de la Chine la façon particulière que la
Chine d'exercer son influence je crois
que pour notre pays comme pour l'Union
européenne en général
nous devons situer cette question dans
le cadre du triptyque européen qui fait
cacher dans la foi un partenaire sur
certains domaines en particulier en
matière commerciale concurrent
certainement en tout cas dans ce domaine
du commerce et un rival systémique avec
ce troisième pilier qui prend plus
d'importance mais nous n'avons pas
vocation à modifier ce triptyque
européen avant la réunion avec les pays
du Pacifique samedi que j'évoquais nous
étions réunis la veille dans un format à
27 les 27 ministres des Affaires
étrangères des États membres de l'Union
européenne pour parler longuement on a
fait pratiquement toute la journée
justement de notre stratégie vis-à-vis
de la Chine
ceci étant dit et vous l'avez dit
monsieur le sénateur au titre de ce
partenariat nous avons
[Musique]
la volonté de relancer les échanges
humains après trois ans de pandémie et
de refermement de la Chine sur elle-même
l'enjeu va au-delà évidemment des sols
échanges humains mais aussi
dessiner à
encourager ce qu'il porte de meilleures
compréhension entre les uns et les
autres donc nous faisons régulièrement
des points avec nos partenaires chinois
je les fais la semaine dernière avec
Monsieur le nouveau ministre des
Affaires étrangères monsieur chingang
pour progresser et renouveler nos
demandes en particulier dans le domaine
académique dans le domaine scientifique
parce que nous y avons intérêt sans
porter atteinte à l'autonomie stratégie
que nous cherchons par ailleurs à
développer il faut bien sûr faire preuve
de vigilance
alors les nos partenaires chinois nous
indiquent qu'ils sont ouverts à une
meilleure reprise des échanges et nous
aurons dans le cadre des trois dialogues
stratégiques économiques commerciales et
portant sur les échanges humains en fin
d'année notre dialogue 2 au niveau sur
les échanges humains peut-être cette
vigilance n'a pas été
suffisante dans le passé je crois
qu'elle était plus forte en France que
dans un pays où j'ai eu l'honneur de
représenter mon pays jusqu'à il y a un
peu moins d'un an mais en effet il y a
des sujets de préoccupation qui relèvent
davantage du ministère de l'Intérieur
que du ministère dont j'ai la charge
mais je ne n'irai pas que la relance des
échanges humains doit aller de pair avec
en effet la nécessaire
vigilance et puis monsieur Center vous
l'avez évoqué la question des droits de
l'homme elle est toujours présente dans
notre dialogue elle n'est pas la plus
simple aborder avec la Chine nous le
faisons souvent discrètement dans des
tenter peut-être mais de l'abordons
toujours ça a été fait dans le cadre de
la dernière visite d'État du président
de la République je peux vous assurer
et bien sûr mais j'ai déjà parlé du
développement
de nos capacités en termes
d'informations de veille de lutte contre
la désinformation
le développement d'une information de
qualité fait partie de nos priorités
donc nous avons des programmes de
formation
qui concerne un certain nombre de pays
lointains puisque nous parlions de la
Chine mais aussi plus proche nous avons
ouvert pour aider l'Ukraine par exemple
les journalistes indépendants à couvrir
la zone ukrainienne ou vers un hub
Bucarest où je me suis rendue et
nous envisageons j'y suis non seulement
très ouverte à titre personnel mais la
France bien sûr aussi notamment par
l'aide qu'elle apporte à la Moldavie
dans le cadre de la préparation du
deuxième sommet de la communauté
politique européenne nous avons déjà
fait beaucoup pour l'aider dans ce mec
compris concrètement en voyant des gens
en envoyant des matériels
mais ça fait partie du soutien que on
lui apporte et qu'on souhaite lui
apporter et qui est indispensable
allez j'ai encore quatre je crois que la
PPR au lieu de mort a été
adopté il y a quelques minutes je ne
pouvais pas étendre devant vous mais je
le président assurer la représentation
du gouvernement mais je remercie Olivier
belge de l'avoir et d'avoir brillamment
représenté le pôle à faire cet étrangère
alors 4 dernières questions je vais
demander aux orateurs d'être concis
parce que je me suis engagé vis-à-vis
d'un certain nombre d'entre vous de pas
trop
chlore cette séance trop tard à cause
des transports vers vos départements
respectifs Michel Gréau
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre d'abord merci pour votre exposé
et vous dire que on se réjouit du
travail effectué notamment la libération
des prisonniers et en même temps
l'évacuation des 1000 personnes du
Soudan
parmi les différents conflits madame la
ministre sur le Sudan justement depuis
les affrontements
qui ont éclaté il y a trois semaines de
nombreuses personnes ont franchi la
frontière du Tihad pour échapper à la
violence des milliers d'autres pour
arriver dans les semaines à venir les
nouveaux arrivants s'ajoutent au nombre
massifs de réfugiés déjà hébergé au
Tchad un tiers de la population
dépendait déjà de l'aide alimentaire
internationale plus largement selon
l'ONU se serait près de 2011 5 de
personnes de personnes supplémentaires
au Soudan qui risque de souffrir de la
fin au cours des prochains mois en
raison de la poursuite des combats il
s'agit d'une course contre la montre
étant que la saison des pluies commence
en juin et que l'accès à de nombreuses
régions du Tchad sera coupé madame la
ministre pourriez-vous nous informer sur
la stratégie adoptée d'une part en
matière de droit d'asile suite à
l'engagement du gouvernement respecter
la convention de Genève et enfin que
compte verser la France comme subvention
supplémentaire à l'ONU au regard de la
gravité de la situation et si oui quel
montant merci merci Michel Jean-Marc
todeskini merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la ministre de votre exposé
je vais être très court parce que le
président veut qu'on soit très court
même si certains ont été très longs mais
c'est vrai que le temps avance donc moi
c'est ma question vous avez évoqué pas
cher al-Assad
puis bien sûr à participer après demain
à la réunion de la Ligue arabe quelle va
être la position de la France pour
éviter une photo à la cop28 parce que là
il est invité aussi officiellement donc
il y aura une réaction
de l'Union européenne il est toujours
aujourd'hui sous sanctions
donc voilà je vais très court je voulais
parler de la Turquie mais comme c'est
capté je pense il vaut mieux qu'on ait
un débat en dehors de une captation
merci
merci Jean-Marc Michael Valley
dans j'ai une ou deux questions j'ai une
question que m'a transmet à une connerie
du fait de sa présence à la pépère au
lot de mort
madame la ministre bonsoir ma première
question porte sur une question de
principe et de règles je voudrais que
vous puissiez nous préciser quelle est
la règle lorsque le département lorsque
le ministère souhaite mener une mission
d'évaluation je vous pose cette question
notamment du fait que a été confirmé
dans la presse récemment le fait que le
président de Capgemini monsieur Paul
Hermelin et chargé d'une mission
d'évaluation avec une lettre de mission
dont vous êtes cossignataire pour je
résume pour améliorer la question des
prises de rendez-vous et les traitements
sur la question des visas et de
s'intéresser notamment par ce biais là
au fonctionnement des postes consulaires
avons-nous les ressources suffisantes
c'est une question rhétorique de ma part
au sein de l'inspection générale du
ministère et faire étrangères et
qu'est-ce qui amène à faire appel à des
compétences extérieures je précise par
avance que
la gratuité de la mission qui est donc
faite pro-bonho non seulement n'est pas
une façon de rassurer mais même plutôt
un point d'alerte qui a été pointé dans
le cadre des auditions et du rapport
rendu par la commission d'enquête
parlementaire du Sénat sur l'influence
croissante des cabinets conseils ou la
question du pro-bonhot a été
caractérisée comme quelque chose comment
dire de d'assez d'assez flou et pas
forcément de nature à rassurer voilà
quand c'est gratuit c'est peut-être que
c'est pas gratuit d'une manière ou d'une
autre avons-nous un aspection générale
les ressources et les qualités
nécessaires pour mener ces émissions
d'évaluation
deuxième point sur ce n'est pas évident
d'essayer de caractériser une
intégralité du monde bien sûr être
définir les zones et vous avez fait un
exposé le plus exhaustif possible on
vous en remercie sauf erreur de ma part
la question en elle-même de la
Méditerranée prise en tant que tel même
si vous l'avez traité par d'autres biais
n'a pas été abordé
c'est l'année la plus mortelle en
Méditerranée nous en sommes déjà à plus
de 400 être humain décédés pendant les
traversées cette année qui seraient
l'année la plus la plus dramatique
avons-nous encore une capacité
d'indignation ou est-ce qu'on est en
train de s'habituer et dans ce cadre-là
y a-t-il des signaux forts que le
gouvernement français souhaite ou peu
encore envoyer dernier point ma collègue
Hélène commémoré me demande de bien
vouloir vous interroger sur le fait que
la cellule tolérance zéro du ministère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
est compétentes pour tous les agents du
ministère qu'il soit titulaires ou
contractuels mais la question c'est
qu'en est-il des personnels et notamment
entre guillemets recrutés locaux qui
exercent au sein de l'établissement
conventionnés ou partenaires du Réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger et
qui ne relèverait pas de la cellule
tolérance zéro pas plus que de l'Agence
pour l'enseignement français à
l'étranger vers qui ces personnes
lorsque le cas se présente son tel
amenées ou appelées à se tourner
s'agit-il des postes diplomatiques
sachant que notre personnel diplomatique
lui-même est désormais plus sensibilisé
à ces questions je vous remercie merci
Mickaël enfin de Ludovic et
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour votre exposé brillant
et exhaustif sur l'ensemble des
situations de du monde j'aurais une
question relativement courte notamment
dans le cadre de l'aide que peut
apporter la France à l'Ukraine nous
pensons forcément dans ce cas-là
immédiatement à l'aide humanitaire et la
logistique qui l'accompagne
nous pensons également
à l'aide à l'aide militaire et
économique mais nous pensons nous
pensons relativement peu à l'aide
juridique qu'un pays pourrait donner et
souvent ce dossier est réduit à la
portion congrue or dans le dossier dit
des avoir rue des avoirs gelés ce
dossier pose de vastes questions
juridiques tant la différence est grande
entre gelée et confisqué est importante
étant entre les avoir d'entité publique
notamment des réserves de banque et des
avoirs de personnes privées là aussi
diffère alors un groupe de travail a été
mis en place au niveau de l'Union
européenne pour travailler sur ce sujet
avec notamment l'Estonie en tête qui a
bien l'intention de jouer un rôle majeur
madame la ministre comment positionner
vous la France dans la résolution de ce
problème juridique complexe mais au
combien passionnant et avez-vous
l'intention de travailler aux côtés de
notre garde des sceaux sur sur ce sujet
je rappelle quelques chiffres quand même
les avoir représentent 300 milliards
issus de réserves de banque et plusieurs
dizaines de milliards issus de domaines
privés pour un coup de remise en état de
l'Ukraine estimée après de mille
milliard
merci
à la mamie malheureusement je dois être
à la présidence je devrais déjà y être
mais je vais laisser la présidence à
Olivier Cadic pour
présider le temps de vous répondre en
vous remerciant pour toutes les
indications et d'exposer
particulièrement complet que vous avez
fait sur la situation du monde Olivier
conclure merci
merci monsieur le Président
pardonnez-moi mesdames et c'est moi qui
ai été un peu longue je le réalise
madame la sénatrice merci de merci de
l'hommage que vous avez rendu au
personnel du ministère quand il le faut
voyez que ils sont là efficaces
la crise qui continue au Soudan
en effet se traduit par une situation
humanitaire qui est difficile pour
de très nombreux soudanais à tel point
qu'il y a déjà des réfugiés dans dans
des pays voisins
la situation humanitaire dans le pays
qui est le même est difficile mais avec
des difficultés taxées bien sûr et puis
impact sur les pays voisins avec
des risques pour les personnes mais une
inquiétude aussi de la part de ces pays
alors nous donnons
une aide humanitaire dans les sols le
chiffre n'est pas encore public mais
nous avions décidé tout de suite de
donner déjà plus d'une dizaine de
millions d'euros prix sur les fonds de
crise de mon ministère et nous allons
devoir accroître cette aide
l'oscilloschique n'est pas publique si
j'ai conscience que cette captation va
le rendre public mais
ça c'est très herbe je vais vous le
donner puisqu'il est plutôt vertueux
que l'inverse puisque nous allons plus
de plus que doublé pour atteindre 27
millions d'euros
la principalement au Tchad et au Sudan
et prioritairement bien sûr pour pour
les déplacer
sur les demandes d'asile
notre ambassade est fermée la carte
fermée
et donc les demandeurs de visa doivent
déposer leurs dossier auprès des
représentations dans les pays voisins il
n'y a pas moyen de de faire autrement
dès lors qu'ils sont présents dans ces
pays
en situation régulière et donc la
recevabilité de ces dossiers elle est
évaluée
d'ores et déjà le cas par les services
consulaires compétents
nous faisons aussi dans le cadre du
respect du droit commun donc dans le
cadre voilà des contrôles de sécurité
également en prenant en compte les
risques migratoires de certaines
demandes j'ajoute bien évidemment madame
la sénatrice que nous avons d'ores et
déjà accueillis des personnes qui
[Musique]
relèvent du droit d'asile et son a comme
réfugiés au sens de la Convention de
Genève notamment des activistes comme
Madame Nasrid el Saim qui est par
ailleurs l'une des lorettes du prix
Marianne créée par mon ministère
monsieur sénateur todeskini vous vous
êtes inquiété mais je l'avais fait avant
vous de se rapprochement de cette
réintégration
de Bachar el-Assad au sein de la Ligue
arabe
j'en dédie ce qu'il fallait en dire et
j'insistais je veux le faire à nouveau
sur le fait que la lutte contre
l'impunité fait partie de ce qui peut
amener
la payer la stabilité dans un pays nous
ne devons pas l'oublier et il n'y aura
pas de possibilités
de normaliser des relations lorsque
nous ne pourrons pas constater une vraie
évolution
tous les pays arabes qui ont procédé à
ce mouvement inédit ont plutôt tendance
à oublier cet aspect des choses raison
pour laquelle je veux le rappeler je
l'ai dit par exemple à mes homologues
égyptiens et jordaniens que je voyais au
milieu de semaine dernière dans un autre
cadre
qui sont d'ailleurs conscients des des
différences ou des nuances que nous
avons les uns les autres même si
eux-mêmes je les dis en nom au sein des
pierres ils sont pas tous unanimes pour
ce qui concerne la COP 28 je ne crois
pas que les invitations soient d'ores et
déjà émises même si nous avons bien noté
l'expression publique récente des
dirigeants des Émirats arabes unis je
rappelle que les invitations sont émises
par le pays organisateur et non pas par
les Nations unies ou par
la Coop elle-même
j'espère que nous ne serons pas dans
cette situation
monsieur sénateur vallée vous m'avez
interrogé sur deux points la mission
Hermelin pour prononcer
le nom de la personnalité qui a aidé
cette mission d'évaluation les
personnalités sont choisies librement
vous savez qu'il je l'ai dit il a rendu
son rapport d'excellentes qualités
Capgemini gagnera rien je ne crois pas
qu'il soit dans ces sujets il agit vous
l'avez dit sans rémunération de la faire
un motif de soupçon je me permets de
dire que c'est un pack je ne franchirais
pas évidemment qui est même un peu
choquant et il a été assisté
efficacement car son rapport est de
qualité par quatre inspecteurs
de réflexions Générale des Affaires
étrangères et d'inspection générale du
mystère de l'intérieur je ne sais pas si
le rapport sera publique mais vous me
donnez évidemment l'envie de vous le
transmettre comme ça vous pourrez juger
de sa qualité sur
la question plus précise que vous posez
sur les opérateurs et les dispositifs
utiles qui nous permettent de déceler
des comportements inappropriés chaque
opérateur elle revient à chaque
opérateur de mettre en place son
dispositif il est donc loisible à chacun
d'entre eux de le faire
enfin j'ai été interrogée si je ne me
trompe pas dans mes fiches et dans mes
notes sur le gel des avoir russes
c'est une question qui a été abordée par
les dirigeants conseils européens en fin
d'année dernière reconseillé européen de
décembre avec demande de regarder ce
qu'il est possible de faire pour passer
du gel
qui est la conséquence des sanctions et
la situation actuelle
une utilisation possible de ses avoirs
qui se monte à plusieurs centaines de
milliards d'euros de dollars on compte
comme on veut
prioritairement évidemment au profit de
l'Ukraine qui souffre de l'agression
russe nous devons agir dans le cadre du
droit et la
confiscation des avoirs est évidemment
impossible en droit leur utilisation
soulève des questions juridiques
complexes il y a un mandat du Conseil
européen pour travailler sur ces sujets
le service juridique du conseil il
travaille à celui de la commission aussi
et il n'y a pas de solution et pas plus
dans d'autres pays étrangers il me
semble pour le moment qui soit
pleinement respectueuse
des règles de droit cela étant dit nous
continuons d'y travailler d'une part et
d'autre part mais vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le sénateur le gel des avoir et
d'ores et déjà une mesure efficace comme
comme vous l'avez relevé et par ailleurs
je terminerai par là
nous avons franchi un nouveau pas avec
la décision qui a été prise hier au
Conseil de l'Europe de créer ça peut
être le début d'un travail qui pourrait
permettre une utilisation des avoir si
nous trouvions la façon juridiquement
correcte des procédés décision donc du
conseil de d'ouvrir un registre du
recensement des dommages subis par
l'Ukraine et imputable à la Russie donc
ça peut être un premier pas sur la façon
future peut-être d'utiliser les avoir
gelés au profit de l'Ukraine
merci Madame la Ministre
des questions de Michael Valley de mon
collègue Michael Valley il a aussi
évoqué le nombre de morts dans la
Méditerranée avec les chiffres
importants
dans les quelques notes que je prenais
l'occasion
évidemment de vous répondre que non
seulement il n'y a pas indifférence mais
il y a action de l'Union européenne et à
titre bilatéral d'un certain nombre
d'États je souhaite appeler de mes vœux
une coopération franco-italienne
renforcée pour prévenir les départs qui
se produisent plus nombreux désormais de
Tunisie que de Libye car depuis le début
de cette année
la les départs en province de Tunisie
ont considérablement repris et dépasse
en nombre avec les dangers qui
s'attachent les départs de la Libye la
Tunisie est en
un état mieux organisé que la lubie qui
n'allait pas encore suffisamment nous
espérons pouvoir dans un cadre européen
et la Commission
un programme
dont on débat avec elle qui peut-être
pourrait connaître une une avancée au
moment du Conseil européen de mi juin
il y a des fonds disponibles en tout cas
il faudra regarder qu'elles peuvent être
les engagements de la Tunisie par elle
l'octroi de fond supplémentaire s'il le
fait y en avoir et puis la France comme
l'Italie réfléchit aussi à des actions
bilatérales
évidemment ce sont des drames
humains terribles l'ancienne
l'ambassadrice de France en Italie qui
les a vu à une autre époque ne peut que
sympathiser avec ce que vous dites
merci beaucoup madame la ministre à la
fois pour ces propos très humains et
vous remercier aussi et passer le
message à tout le ministère pour leurs
efforts effectivement ce travail
formidable pour au Soudan vis-à-vis de
ce de ces mille personnes qui ont pu
revenir et puis là aussi comme ça a été
dit pour les on peut dire certains
otages qui sont dans les prisons et on
sait qu'il y en a encore d'autres et
donc c'est une action silencieuse
discrète qui est faite mais ça fait
plaisir de voir les résultats bravo à
toutes et à tous pour cela merci encore
madame merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci